another week another day in the
apocalypse you know the drill so I'm
going to talk about it now also that's a
spoiler warning for episode seven of the
last of us if you haven't seen episode
seven you're more than welcome to stick
around just know that I'm gonna ruin it
for you right so episode 7 is titled
Left Behind which is the title of the
DLC for The Last of Us which is the
chapter we're covering it's it's a
flashback now that Joel's been impaled
by a baseball bat Ellie's scrambling and
then it flashes back to her hanging out
with a friend Riley the events that were
covered in The Last of Us Left Behind
DLC and this actually affords me an
opportunity most timely this video is a
little different than the other Last of
Us videos I've done because I myself I
haven't played the DLC I know I've told
a couple people that they're like that's
weird DLC is hard for me man I'm
invested in this world and in this story
and by the time the DLC comes out I'm
like I'm on other things so I never
played The Last of Us DLC which means
I'm watching this episode not comparing
it to the game as my I know people are
like you shouldn't do that I didn't grow
up on Vulcan I don't know how to turn
that [__] off but it was cool to take in
the drama of the episode not caring
whether or not it was accurate just did
it play well so storm Reed plays Riley I
thought her and Bella Ramsay had great
chemistry together storm raid was also
great in that was missing or searching
that's one of the two but this was a
good time for this flashback episode to
happen you know we've seen why Joel is
very standoffish but then after Ellie
had that monologue of like everyone who
I've ever cared about is either dead or
gone we see the episode that feeds into
that and really it's Ellie hanging out
in this facility where eventually she
will become you know part of the
establishment Riley's left that to
become a firefly these established
groups one could call them
establishments who work to fight The
Establishment they're just trying to
usurp that establishment to make their
establishment The Establishment you're
going to be just as bad as the other
guys I like the fact of the show at
least does touch on that point is Riley
and Ellie go to their small it's
actually very endearing and sweet you
know I guess that's a common human theme
people on escalators do exactly what
Ellie did on escalators if you haven't
you have one homework assignment after
this video go to an escalator turn
around and walk opposite the escalator
so you don't move at all
everyone has it if you haven't done that
I'm concerned for you my favorite part
of you know what my favorite part's
gonna be how long have you known me
that's right MK2 Ellie had a little MK2
looked like a newspaper clipping this is
the title of MK2 I was like okay that's
cool I didn't know I'd actually hear the
Chimes hear those notes those lovely
notes in full arcade Glory that's what
took me back is the fact that it's in an
arcade and you hear that
I'm like well that's that's Mortal
Kombat 2 but with the ambience of an
arcade now I'm being taken back that's
actually pretty incredible I like the
fact that they actually had the music
and sound effects from the game I mean
there is a connective tissue there HBO
Warner Brothers Warner Brothers WB Games
WB Games netherrum Studios netherrum
studios Mortal Kombat 2 right let me
just use the TV shows showing someone
playing a game or like wow Mom thanks
for the Super Nintendo this racing game
is great I don't know why I'm button
mashing the living [__] out of this
controller that's definitely also not
for a Super Nintendo but that's how we
do it on TV no actually games like this
unless it's you know tattoo Chris yet
here we are I mean they're button
mashing absolutely but that it feels
different than other shows and movies
that have button mashing because they
wouldn't know how to play Mortal Kombat
2 though Riley knew how to do two
fatalities I like that in the apocalypse
she's researching the important [__]
because it is I will say when Riley did
Molina's fatality she does like a three
button combination I was like that's not
that fatality although the sound effect
did happen before she did that so she
might have just done it look in the 90s
we had some really ritualistic [__] when
it came to an ass beating in Mortal
Kombat 2. some people dance some people
just hit buttons some people just went
with the controllers they were intense
times my friends regardless the point is
Riley is down with those times that
impresses me that baraka fatality
they'll back four down four low punch
that's legitimately what the fatality is
so it's like what
thank you for thank you I love on-screen
video game accuracy it's a thing with me
as for them paddling around in the mall
one thing was always certain
this is not going to end well so you see
where Ellie gets her bite from also
Riley took a bite and they're they're
both just chilling there did we kill
each other did we kill ourselves I don't
like that option maybe we'll just sit
here cool thing is I don't know how the
game Illustrated it like I said it's
like did it just leave them there with
their bites it might be a flashback for
another time for dramatic purposes you
know what you need to know Ellie's alive
Riley got bit we know how that goes down
I mean on the basis that Riley is not
being hauled across the country to go to
this Firefly facility for a cure maybe
it's the most clever marketing ever it's
like you want to see what happened to
Riley buy the game now for 69.99 full
price for the third time and there seems
to be two more episodes left in these
last two episodes are going to be
fantastic fantastic I mean say that on
the faith of the rest of the show
leading up to this point I'm just saying
knowing what the next two episodes
should be
um good stuff really light-hearted [__]
too it's gonna be fine don't even worry
about it bring the kids I said The Last
of Us episode seven titled Left Behind
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]